[Applause]
and the oscar goes to
the year that i won an academy award for
the reader actually even as i say it i
slightly can't quite believe that it
really happened because i'd gotten very
good at losing kate winslet
[Applause]
it was the seventh time i had been
nominated honestly i can remember it
like it was yesterday
it's almost as though there's an
earthquake that happens from your toes
up this sort of overwhelming feeling of
shock
the most extraordinary part for me was
getting up onto the stage
turning around to face the audience and
to see that they were standing up
my speech did go according to plan i had
actually written something and i had
learned it i'd be lying if um
i haven't
made a version of this speech
before i think i was probably
eight years old and staring into the
bathroom mirror
and this would have been a shampoo
bottle because i thought you know if
this does happen i don't want to panic
and i want to make sure that i remember
everything and remember all the
important people especially my mum and
dad who are in this room somewhere dad
whistle or something because then i'll
know where you are
[Applause]
i had been in berlin with stephen dawdry
to do a little mini celebration with all
the cast and crew and i said when i tug
my ear like this that means i love you
all there was no division between the
cast and the crew on this film and
that's what made it so special
somehow in that moment the dry mouth the
racing heart i remember to do the tug on
my ear you know this is the stuff of
dreams you know this is the stuff that
as children you watch on television you
think god that world you know that
untouchable world i was one of those
kids too
i can't
be anything other than utterly grateful
for the moment that it happened to me
and how special it was
you